all right so one night I'm saying I get
a phone call that like something
happened to one of my friends
and they were gone they weren't coming
back for a while and uh so I was you
know it was it was a [ __ ] up day real
paranoid [ __ ] up day for me right
I wasn't involved in none of it but it
just was very close to me and you know
so I was home I remember I was laying
downstairs in the living room in my and
my phone rang and I'm like
hello he's like yo what's up bro just
want to let you know man [ __ ]
is proud of you
and I was like all right good looking
I'm like who is this he's like a shoe
man I was like oh I was like all right
where you at I don't know I don't even
know what this is but I was locked up
with so many different people that
someone's coming he got my number right
I'm not talking crazy with him all right
we can talk like who is this you know
what I'm saying like where do I know you
from
nah man you um
you weren't locked up with me I'm way
out west I'm like no I was out west PA
too he's like no no I'm out west I'm in
California locked up
so I just want to let you know we've
been looking at your progress
[ __ ] is proud of you and [ __ ]
so I was like all right
I appreciate it I said shoot where do I
know you from he said my name is Shu my
name is shook
I said
shook I said is this sure what's your
last what's your last name he said
there's only one shook [ __ ]
Suge Knight
so I was like
I'm saying I was like all right he's
like look I'm gonna have Scott
and Steve call you you know get with you
like all right well if this is really
you I apologize
just a random I don't know how Suge
Knight got my number right you know what
I'm saying
so the next day
Scott Storch FaceTime me I was like yo
we're gonna we're gonna get it in we
just we just got put on to you by you
know
Suge Knight I was like damn I was like
all right and I never even got to talk
to dude again because you can't call
back that's crazy I'm saying and then
you know it went dry for a while like
the whole summer went by and then my
homie hit me and was like yo
I just because I put a screenshot up
once when I started FaceTiming
yeah of course
put it up so that that got you know the
battery in one of my homies backs to
just keep the same way I was at you I
got some thorough people around me that
are constantly just like I'll breathing
just like all this BT [ __ ] you know
so like he's like yeah I'm going out
there [ __ ] with him you're coming I'm
like all right come on let me go out
there get with Steve get with Scott we
got a record in the tuck you know I got
a Beat by storage you know in the talk
great guy yeah man so
you know should be happening crazy
should be happening I mean so you still
haven't talked to Suge Knight huh nah
that's so crazy that like whatever you
were doing like got into the on his
radar while he's incarcerated
yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] wild man no
you know
you know it ain't easy It Ain't Easy
where that uh came from
with some cats from Jersey was that
shade four five one day
you know I guess they were in close
touch with
dude over here and you know they put
them I mean I found that out later
but um yeah man
I don't know if he's ever supposed to
get out but I'm sure if he does he'll
meet him one day or visit him I don't
know oh yeah no man like I said man I
wish everybody the best like I know
everybody you know um that's not a
um I know that that dude's been through
a lot of situations with a lot of people
of course of course of course I mean
yeah yeah but you know but that's like
that's their business I'm saying 100